I'm tomorrow saying reading for reviewer
Richard weakling Ghost Recon breakpoint
is uneven and conflicted it offers a
near identical core gameplay loop of
open-world espionage and shooting as
wildlands did but it's also a messy
hodgepodge of disparate ideas shoehorned
in half-baked and our place the addition
of loot and an ever increasing gear
score fits into the standard template of
Ubisoft recent open-world games
breakpoint includes these light RPG
mechanics but the implementation of its
lucre and feels like a severe
afterthought there are numerous pieces
of armor to find and equip as you
explore the fictional island of Aurora
the numbers attached to each one will
raise or lower your gear score but the
effect this has on gameplay is entirely
inconsequential rare loot might include
small buffs yet the effects of these
buffs are also negligible a level 5
beanie offers as much protection as a
level 75 helmet so these numbers only
exist to raise a gear score that's
nothing more than a flimsy
representation of your progress it's
difficult to care when there are no
tangible benefits to picking one piece
of armor over another choosing which
weapon to roll with requires slightly
more deliberation although this is
mainly due to your preference for
specific weapon types as opposed to the
number attached to each firearms
function similar to armor with rare
weapons receiving minuscule busts two
aspects like reload speed and recoil
reduction again the impact these stats
have on the gameplay is paltry at best
especially because shooting and
breakpoint is still geared towards
landing headshots for instant kills
weapons feel impactful as a result of
this successfully capturing the rush of
being an elite Special Ops soldier that
can take out four or five enemy
combatants in a matter of seconds but
this also means that the rarity of
weapons and the gear score attached to
them is ultimately meaningless you can
wander into an area recommended for
players with a gear score of 140 with a
significantly lower score and still kill
every enemy without breaking a sweat the
amount of freedom will be commendable if
it didn't shine a derisive light on how
shallow the RPG mechanics are break
points paper-thin survival mechanics are
similarly underdeveloped hinting at a
tense experience that never comes to
fruition you can carry a floss that you
can refill in lakes rivers and even in
someone's backyard swimming pool for
that sweet taste of chlorine water is
used to replenish any law stamina you've
misplaced by overexerting usually by
rolling down a hillside because Aurora
is nearly bereft of flat ground as a
result traversing on foot revolves
around spending a lot of time sliding
down undulating slopes this quickly
drains your stamina sending you into an
uncontrollable roll that inflicts damage
with each nick and bump health
regenerates over time but if you suffer
either a minor or major injury and don't
want to hobble everywhere you need to
use a syringe for instant pain relief or
spend longer wrapping yourself up in
bandages syringes are finite yet you
have an infinite supply of bandages that
almost makes the mechanic moot the
gameplay loop is almost identical to
wild lenses you send a drone into the
sky survey an enemy base and mark
targets before infiltrating in whatever
manner you see fit navigating through a
heavily fortified compound without being
seen is still inherently satisfying each
one is usually designed in a way so that
there are a number of enemies obscured
from your drones vision you might be
able to pick off a handful of God's from
a distance using a silent sniper rifle
but at some point you'll have to enter
and find the rest
the only thing impeding your stealthy
espionage is the fact that you can't
move sideways while prone instead you
end up with these awkward animations
because you can only turn at right
angles taking cover is overly cumbersome
too you do it automatically but what the
game deems as cover is inconsistent from
one low wall to the next and even if you
do manage to get behind an object
whether you can shoe over it or not is
another question though this will be a
bigger problem if the AI were the least
bit competent enemies in break point are
to the point where playing on the
highest difficulty doesn't present a
significantly harder challenge
bottlenecks like corridors and doorways
are by far the worst enemy sit down one
end of a straight corridor and it
doesn't take long for the bodies to pile
up you can even shoot the ground at the
entrance to a base and kill each enemy
who appears to investigate factoring the
disappointing fact that enemies don't so
much as flinch when getting shot in the
body and none of this is conducive to an
enjoyable combat experience shooting
other players in the ghost war PvP mode
fares better since real people tend to
have their wits about them compared to
the AI unlike wildlands breakpoint
cleverly unifies progression across both
single and multiplayer all of your
weapons and skills carry over and the
rewards you unlock can be bought back
into single-player - the best matches in
ghost war are tense Affairs especially
since you only have a single life unless
a teammate can perform a successful
revive the issue with break points
cumbersome cover mechanic an awkward
prone movement are only exacerbated in
multiplayer however it can also be
difficult just getting into a match of
ghosts or due to relatively frequent
server issues break point is an always
online game even if you're playing alone
in single-player the servers have run
into a few problems since the game's
full release and it's incredibly
frustrating to be kicked back to the
main menu and have to restart a mission
all over again when you're not even
engaging with the multiplayer portion of
the game if you want to do so and the
servers are running smoothly and you can
get some like-minded friends together
there's definitely some fun to be had in
break points four-person co-op as
silently clearing a base of enemies is
more gratifying with other people
there is however some dissonance between
co-op and the story painting you as a
lone soldier although this is much more
egregious in breakpoint social hub you
can play the whole game solo but mission
givers all hang out in this homely cave
where you'll also find 50 or so other
players your character is literally
called Nomad and yet you're in a space
with a bunch of other nomads all
standing around the same NPC like it's
an MMO and the story's not great either
way Jon Bernthal elevates every scene
he's in chewing up the scenery to
deliver simmering monologues befitting
of a villain with a dubious moral code
the writing is mostly cheesy though with
some flat voice acting and predictable
twists the social hub seems to exist to
guide you towards breakpoints myriad
microtransactions you can buy tattoos
shirts masks hats weapons vehicles and
more purchasing in-game money also comes
in denominations that ensure you're
always spending more than you need you
don't have to engage with any of this
stuff and it's easy enough to ignore but
this micro transaction structure is
predatory by design it would make sense
if the addition of loot were in the
service of guiding people to spend real
money on better guns but even then the
stats are so meaningless it will take a
lot of convincing there's some
surprising fun to be had stealthily
infiltrating enemy compounds and playing
with friends but breakpoint is still a
generic and distinctly subpar game it's
essentially every Ubisoft open-world
game rolled into one
failing to excel in any one area or
establish its own identity breakpoint is
a messy confused game and a ghost of the
series is former self
[Music]